hey guys it's Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
soda saga level 180 commentary video
with some tips this is a really tough
level one that people ask about in our
group all the time so I thought I'd go
ahead and make this extra video to show
you some of the important decisions and
see how I worked my way through it the
main thing I played this a few times now
trying to make the video and the main
thing that I have trouble with and I'm
sure everybody else does is getting four
pieces of gum that are in the corners
there that have a coil in front so
mainly you know I'm clearing up some
space so I can make some specials and
things but I'm looking for opportunities
where I can go after those and it sort
of works like if I um if I clear out
most of the gum in the middle then I can
kind of use my fish and you know just
some other choices that I have to kind
of go after there's like a strike we'll
go across them hit them they won't
spread the gum as fast like here I can
hit two of them look I make this and
because the the blockers are still in
place they won't necessarily pass the
the gum around so you know if you can if
you can clear them out while the the
Bacher's are still in place it'll keep
the gum dump from spreading as much as
it would otherwise and you can see one
of my fish here went up and cleared the
one layer of the gum off at the top too
when I did that so
but right there yeah you can see so I'd
like to get rid of the one at the bottom
right now but I don't really have a good
shot at doing that so I'm just gonna
look for more chances to bring candies
down and make stripes fish plus stripe
stripe plus wrapped and you can see on
the right side the gums not growing the
top left it's not growing but at the
bottom left now it's time to grow out on
the thing so I want to try to control
that and now it'll be able to grow from
the top left - so it's nice to get rid
of that licorice coil there but it's
also a little tricky once that happens
because well I mean it's not any more
tricky but it it just makes for a
cascading kind of effect so you won't
always get exactly what you want as far
as when you try it if you're trying to
make an actual match over it so here we
want to you know kind of attack this
corner since it's there's no blocker in
front of it anymore making the fish
first because that purple match won't
get disturbed
and it didn't go our wanted but I was
able to set the fish off and you can see
I'm just gonna keep trying to make more
of them and see what I can accomplish
that way a fish I mean obviously up like
most levels but especially the best
combo here would be to have a colouring
can here color bomb plus a fish so we
have a little bit of room where we might
be able to get something like that
together and we want to just like a
chocolate level you know we want to be
able this to fish together there's a
good there's a good combo here they're
just like the chocolate levels you know
we're gonna want to hit the gum every
once in a while so it doesn't just
continue to spread rapidly so we got 13
moves being a what it says eight but
unless we can get rid of one of these
exposed corners it's just gonna keep
spreading
okay here's our color ball then we can
actually miss max it with match it with
this fish here so that's pretty good
news there's not a lot of yellows on the
board but there's only ten bubblegum
spots and some of them were double
anyways so that cleared out a lot of it
as you can see and now we only have a
groan form source so we should I don't
want to jinx myself but we should be
able to oh yeah we get to get out right
there and that's how you do it so you
know just generally speaking pay
attention to those corners try to hit
them while they're still covered with
blockers by using your fish or stripes
so that you can hopefully clear the gum
before it starts to spread from that
corner and if you don't have any luck
keep trying and you know definitely go
for the color bomb fish or like I said
even to fish together is a good one as
well so hope this helps please subscribe
to the channel so you can get more
helpful how-to videos and like the video
and share it with your friends to help
support us Thanks